The Education Ministry wants to test a teacher evaluation system for K-12 schools...
...and then fully implement it in 2007.
The major teaching unions and associations are largely opposed,...
...so whether inspections are dead on arrival...
...or will be able to perform their intended function no one knows.
Voluntary teacher participation makes the process murkier still...
...because of the prospect of either subversion or resistance to it.
In principle, teacher appraisal by fellow teachers, parents and students,...
...contributes to classroom democratization.
In addition, healthy competition between teachers...
...can be of great help in improving the quality of education,...
...so teacher evaluation should not be opposed unconditionally.
However, the union feels that reality is far more complex.
They insist that the new system should have a format that contributes...
...to the increase in education quality...
...by solving current problems with materials and teaching technique only.
Those who oppose the union's point of view feel that...
...this approach will still allow bad teachers to persist.
Moreover, bad instructors will teach for show at inspection time...
...and not use the information to improve themselves or their teaching.
Furthermore, they feel without accountability the inspection will be worthless.